Alright, let's take a look at how we implemented the playWorldSound function.
Now remember it takes the parameters, first the soundURL representing the sound
that we want to play in the world, and then the x and y position that this
sound should be played at. So first we're going to check if the player is null
for some reason, just as a sanity check. If it is, then we simply return and
don't worry about playing it. If there's no players to hear the sound, does the
sound actually play? And we're going to do a little bit of shorthand here just
to make it a bit easier for us to write for ourselves by shortening
gGameEngine.gMap to just gMap, locally. And now we're going to do the
calculation for fading the volume out. Based upon the distance from the player
that the sound is supposed to be played at. First, we check the viewSize of
the, for the map's viewRect. And we're actually going to do this as a square
rather than as a rectangle for simplicity's sake. So we take the maximum of the
width and the height. Then we multiply it by half, since we don't want the full
width. We only want the half since we're going to set the center of that view
size to be the player's current position. And we want the distance from the
player to the sound. Now, we're going to take the x value, the absolute x
value, from the player position to the sound's x position, and similarly for
the y value. And now, we simply compute the distance function, which is the
same one that you've probably learned in high school, which is the square root
of the x distance squared plus the y distance squared. Now we're going to
normalize that distance, and what we mean by that is we're going to take the
distance to the observer that we've just calculated, and we're going to divide
that by the view size that we calculated earlier to see how many view sizes
from the player we are. Like we talked about four. If we are more than two view
sizes away, then maybe want to start reducing the sound like we discussed. So
in this case, if the normal distance is greater than one view size away, then
we set the norm distance to one, since we're going to reduce the volume by the
norm distance later on, and it doesn't really make sense to have a negative
volume. Norm, norm distance, is for whatever reason less than zero, then we
simply return and don't play. And then we create a call back function. And
immediately calls play sound on that sound object. The path of that sound
object that is and with settings saying looping is false and that volume is the
volume that we have just calculated. So, once this function is written, we'll
have a nice effect where the further the sound is away from a player, the more
quietly it's played until the player can't hear it at all, creating a more
realistic sound environment.